well good morning good afternoon good
evening or good night wherever you may
be in the world today but we want to
welcome to today's live broadcast the
surgeon's tool box outcomes are only as
good as a contents of the box mr
selfridge until and I will be your
moderator for this session we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge this light window by
clicking on the screen icon on the lower
right corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems beyond or
here in this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the Lord left side of the
window I would like to introduce today's
speaker on my very good friend dr. Japan
Baron dr. Baron earned a Bachelor of
Science degree in animal science from
the University of Delaware a veterinary
medical doctorate from the University of
Pennsylvania and a master of science
degree from the University of Washington
dr. Barron is head of innovative animal
technologies and training at novartis
institutes for biomedical research his
current work centers on the refinement
and development of surgical and bio
methodology training programs including
efficiency and objective competency and
proficiency assessment I will now turn
it over to dr. ship on morale for his
presentation so take care of Japan
suppose I say thank you so much more
cell for the introduction and for
moderating the session also like to
thank all the participants for joining
us for this session and I'm very excited
talking about this topic that very often
is emitted when we talk about surgery
one of the things i do want to mention
at the beginning is that we're going to
be addressing a mainly rodent surgery
because rodents are the largest portion
of the animals did we utilize and also
folks that utilize those species don't
necessarily have that imaginary surgical
medical background but a lot of the
items we're going to talk about can also
translate into other areas of surgery
and other species so we're going to talk
about surgical simulation we're going to
be addressing proper selection we're
also going to discuss why we need
appropriate instrumentation with a touch
up on quality of the instruments we're
going to also talk about surgical
procedures that are required to think
about when you are looking at the
packages of the instruments that you
would like to utilize we're also going
to spend actually quite a bit of time on
economics and again that's one of the
areas that very often we do not pay
attention to but it's extremely
important important and we're going to
talk about proper implementation of the
instruments into the surgical procedures
and in a selection process so what are
some of the challenges that we face with
selecting instruments in the biomedical
field in a laboratory animal science
field so on lack of surgical background
and specialization so like I mentioned
most folks that perform routine surgery
don't have surgical medical or
veterinary background and so it's very
varied as they have PhD students
undergrad students veterinary
technicians
and animal technicians and other
technical staff there are also a lot of
companies that sell surgical
instrumentation and there's lack of
nomenclature standardization so one
instrument can be called something
different by different companies which
makes it very challenging identifying
exactly what you need and also comparing
between different components on a human
surgery side of the medical centers they
have procurement specialists so that's
an actual job of a person there that's a
full-time job to assist with procurement
of various surgical instrumentation and
equipment for surgical facilities for
the surgeon in most facilities we don't
have a person that specializes in that
area so again we have to identify what
instrumentation and would equipment we
need there's very often their standard
kids available also for example you
search for rodent surgery or mouse or
rat surgical kids and any of the search
engines you're going to find if quite a
few companies selling those kids but
very often those kids are composed of
five or six instruments and those might
be appropriate for maybe one or two
procedures but they're not appropriate
for more complex procedures so for
example what I have seen is that with
those packages despise six instruments
surgeons will try to perform
subcutaneous implantation of a pump for
example all the way to a kidney
transplant and really that's not
appropriate and we'll discuss that in
more detail why that is so when we think
about appropriate instrumentation the
reason for selecting the instruments
that would give us better outcomes it's
going to allow us to optimize the
procedural outcome
it's going to also thereby decrease the
confounding factors it's certainly going
to decrease mortality and morbidity and
in a long term it's going to decrease
the expense so during this presentation
we're going to spend convention before
quite a bit of time addressing
ergonomics then we're going to step into
selection or procurement of surgical
instrumentation the topics we're not
going to address but are also very
important our magnification and
illumination equipment and also
supportive equipment required for
example for monitoring the animal which
is also helpful for the surgeons so for
example if I'm doing a catheterization
of the left ventricle and a rat I would
like to see how the animals are
responding to that but again that's type
of equipment we're not going to be
addressing today so to economics matter
during routine surgery and why so you
guys have a chat function there so I'm
going to give you a few 30 or 60 seconds
or so forget to type in your answers
there my wood economics but then she
helped you thanks urge me
and you can use that Q&A function there
so we're getting some responses here
it's yes repetitive motion syndrome and
most of you guys agree that it's
important and obviously it does after
many surgeries are done and fatigue will
cause errors ergonomics reduce head and
body fatigue increase speed and
therefore outcome yes explanation mark
more efficient surgery less strain on
the surgeon multiple surgeries in a row
so great so I really appreciate your
responses here so might seem like maybe
going into the choir here but at the
same time we're going to address three
areas of economics and so hopefully
you'll be something new to you guys as
well so do ergonomics really matter so
unaware of physical and mental fatigue
that the surgeon must withstand to
complete procedures so folks who do not
have experience and surgery for example
PhD students it might be challenging for
them to understand the fatigue they can
undergo it's also challenging for folks
without that background to grasp their
ports of ergonomic ly comfortable
surgical instruments to outcome of
surgical procedures so one
the facts that will bring up here that
the food and respiration did the survey
and an estimated fifty percent of 1.3
million unintentional patient injuries
per year and United States hospitals are
due to poor design of medical
instruments if there's a pretty
impressive facts which goes along with
their economics but also why you need
the appropriate instrumentation for
surgical procedures so we're government
cover three subdivisions of ergonomics
of subclasses physical cognitive and
organizational so physical ergonomics as
you can imagine is going to deal with
the surgeons posture biomechanics how
the surgeon is moving are able to move
repetitive motions also the surgical
area layout and handling of instruments
and sutures so physical ergonomics are
influenced by multiple factors you have
viewing sitting and space and will
address this in more detail so for
example for viewing when you're
performing the road and laparoscopy it's
important to how you place the monitor
when you visualizing what you're doing
and the animal so the monitor height
should be 25 degrees below horizontal
plane of your eyes and for procedures
when surgeons change position so if you
have multiple entries into the abdomen
you should have two or even three
monitors and those monitors are not only
helpful for you but also helpful for
your assistance when you talk about
microsurgery it might be seen something
that you necessarily think about using
screens for microsurgery but there is a
initiation or a small movement that's
utilizing monitors there are attached to
microscopes to perform microsurgery and
it's something that
the advantage is already you can see
everything on the screen on the large
screen you don't have to lean over the
microscope but there's also some
challenges with that as well but for the
placement of that monitor that should be
between 10 to 25 degrees below line of
sight and the main challenge with
utilizing monitors for microsurgery if
you now use to them is really the
experience with them and getting used to
utilizing sitting position is extremely
important you really have to have an
adjustable chair and the way you should
be sitting that the spine should be in a
neutral position your hip and knee and
straight line and pearl to the floor and
your feet should be resting flat on the
floor free off to what I see is that
shorter folks will prop themselves with
their toes and told her people will sit
in a position where their knees are
above their hips and again and
introduces additional stress and to your
body lower leg should be appropriately
go to the floor so really your knees and
your hips should be at a 90-degree angle
and your feet as well next should also
be aligned with the spine and not
hunched forward or leaning back because
again it's going to introduce additional
stress and fatigue on your body head
positioning is also very important and
that's something again very often when i
visit different facilities they have
seen we don't really pay a lot of
attention to that so movement of the
arms should be cut or below your wrists
and when you're performing rodent
surgery and really ideally you should
rotate your fingers or your wrists to
minimize the motions because again any
even micro motions you know half a
millimeter to a millimeter when you're
performing a for example wrestler
anastomosis
mouse or a rat I could have a
detrimental effect your forearms should
be rested and that's to limit the
shoulder fatigue as well as provide
stability so one of the things that we
use commonly as saline bags that you can
place your forearms on them and provide
you with the stability and ability also
to remove those forearms without being
just on a flat surface and also what's
really important that the tools the
utilizing should be within your reach so
that you're not leaning all the way over
to grab something from one side or
another side and ideally you should
place your instruments and the same
position each time so not only for
economical perspective but also you
don't have to step away from or move
away from the microscope so then your
eyes would have to refocus back and
forth so you're losing that time there
is the animals and as the thighs so you
want to have those instruments in the
same spot and so you can just easily
reach and grab them so space this slide
is left blank on purpose because the
main point of it that you need a lot of
space and most of the time we don't have
enough space force especially for rodent
surgery most of us don't have surgical
suites dedicated to Road in surgery a
lot of times ridden surgeries perform on
benches we have a lot of other things in
those areas so really you need to make
sure they have enough space or whatever
space you think is enough I would
recommend doubling or tripling that area
you also have to consider with its base
additional equipment that we briefly
mention at the beginning of the
presentations of physiological manager
immigrant yeah anesthesia setup you know
your instruments that there are nicely
laid out and you're not searching
wasting time searching for them so
usually the tables that um we utilize
are at least five feet but usually about
six feet and length and about 40
centimeters and width so now let's talk
about cognitive ergonomics so we talked
about physical ergonomics now we're
going to switch and thought about
cognitive ergonomics so cognitive
ergonomics encompass things such as
mental stress on a surgeon both with the
workload and decision-making as well as
having a skillful surgical outcome so
the surgeon might be stressed because
they have to perform so many procedures
within a day and they might have a very
tight schedule also when you have to
perform for example 20-30
catheterizations you might see that the
first surgery second surgery is faith in
right now but you're not sure if it's
going to be paid in two three four or
five days down a row but at the same
time you continue to perform the same
procedure so that can play an impact
also the relationship of the surgeon
with that equipment so if you are new to
the equipment if you bring a new
surgical instrument and to your facility
sort of utilize that could also add
stress to the surgeon might be one would
like to make sure that the search is
competent and proficient because that if
you're not sure how to perform a
procedure would have an impact on how
stressed you are it's very important to
have an eye and hand coordination you
need to be confident and that goes along
with the competency and proficiency but
if you're not confident again it's just
going to add additional stress to the
surgeon you want to make sure that
you're rested before surgery you know
the you don't have one or two hours of
sleep because one you're going to
fatigue a lot faster you're going to be
stressed as well you also want to make
sure talking about stress here you don't
want to be overly stressed so you really
want to plan appropriately
and also stress can be brought on by
being pressed for time so like I already
mentioned if you're doing you know 30 40
50 procedures within a day that's
certainly going to put pressure on you
and even if consciously you don't think
you're being stress the stress is
definitely there so now we're going to
talk about organizational organ onyx so
these include communication with the
surgical and investigational team I'm
also quality assurance so how do you
make sure that you set up as appropriate
and the outcomes are appropriate proper
delegation of duties to your members of
your team so you want to work with
people who are going to be providing
with the animals and again I know
they're with routine surgery very often
we're responsible for everything but at
least you can work with your team
helping you bringing the animals or
dying the surgical procedure making sure
do you have everything there that's
needed for the surgery and we'll talk
about the little bit more I really the
culture of the workplace environment so
you want in an area where you're
performing surgery you want to make sure
that there is not a lot of traffic there
and again this could be a significant
challenge when you're working in a lab
setting so we're going to lab bench and
other people are coming through and
running around and potentially
interfering with your surgical procedure
so you really want to communicate with
everybody in your area that you're going
to be doing a procedure you want
identify the support staff and that's
something that a few studies have been
done showing on a human surgical side
that one I'm using human and I'm talking
about medical centers where they perform
surgeries on humans and those areas that
having appropriate competent and
proficient staff really increases
that out better outcomes and decreases
mortality and morbidity so planning so
as a surgeon if all the aspects around
the surgery have now been planned out
well that's going to also put stress on
you because you're going to think do I
have the appropriate analgesics and that
i'm going to use after surgery or where
those energies accuse appropriately
pre-surgical medications depending on or
compounds depending which studies you're
performing patient preparation to make
sure they have everything available for
that patient so for example drapes you
know all those different things except
the technique is also very very
important and again we're not going to
be addressing that that here but it's
something has been addressed about
during other presentations within this
conference at the anesthetic protocols
so as a surgeon if you're doing a
thoracic surgery you want to make sure
that everything is addressed and you
have the appropriate and aesthetics but
also a Probie anesthetic setup because
any of those things are going to put a
dish of stress on you and for example at
the end is if you're just the one who
performing surgery if you need to adjust
the anesthesia you want to make sure
that set up in the right and area and
easily reachable to you as a surgeon so
when we think about organizational
organized we should consider the micro
environment and the macro environment so
the micro environment is right around
the animal we performing the surgical
procedure the macro environment is the
whole room for example so like if you
work in a lab setting again people
coming in and out different equipment
being in your way potentially so you
really should assess both of those
environments you also want to make sure
that you have enough sterile instruments
so if you're performing what about
procedures within a day do you have
enough packs available
so you're not running out and trying to
grab instruments between the surgeries
or even worse during the surgeries that
call also goes along with all of the
other pieces of equipment so for example
like suture if you drop a suture on the
floor or on off the sterile area and you
have to replace it you don't want to
need to get up and go get that suture
you should have the suture available and
in place and easily read reachable area
also scheduling a surgical procedure is
very important and that applies a
specific specifically if you're doing
multiple searches within a day and
usually you're going to things are going
to happen and put this you go wrong so
you want to make sure that you give
yourself enough time and between the
surgeries and for the surgeries so again
you don't have that stress upon you that
the number of surgeries that you have
everything has to go the right way and
again stucking of consumable surgical
supplies so I already mentioned suture
material but anything else that you
would need even some basic things like
gloss you want to make sure that that's
available and within an easy reach of
where you're sitting so just to
summarize economics there are three
categories that we should consider
physical cognitive and organizational
and it's really important at each one of
these categories is addressed and
optimized as much as possible in order
to have successful surgical outcome
which is going to lead to appropriate or
good data and decrease the confining
factors so now we're going
gears a little bit and talk about
selection and procurement of surgical
instrumentation so inappropriate
instrumentation selection increases risk
of incorrect tissue handling and
surgical complication so whenever you're
thinking about identifying instruments
or purchasing instruments you really
should keep this in mind and obviously
we'll talk about more detail in the next
few slides so appropriate instrument
instruments are for intended surgical
procedures so I commence at the
beginning of the presentation if you're
thinking about doing a kidney transplant
you're going to need very different
instrumentation that you're performing a
subcutaneous public Plantation or even a
heart transplant or a gastric bypass a
procedure that could be in rodents or
even larger species because this
appropriate instruments will allow you
to perform your procedure correctly and
it's going to lead to appropriate out so
the instrument properties they should
consider are the ergonomics of the
instruments the quality long gentility
as well as affordability so it's really
important to remember that most
instruments are designed with one or two
principal functions so for example a
hemostats you should not utilize them as
needle holders another example using
microsurgical needle holder to grab
suture you should use it to grasp and
hold them anew ver microsurgical needles
and not suture material if you do that
it's going to weaken the suture which
can lead to terry and potentially did
his sense of your anastomosis site and
or closure also grasping larger needles
with micro surgical instruments
can need to a damage of those and where
increase the wear and tear on them so
then when you are actually trying to
scratch smaller needles that's going to
be very challenging to do so suture
holders are very often used or not
actually not utilized in microsurgery
because very often we use other
instruments to grasp suture so there are
appropriate instruments for that for
handling suture material there very
often also referred us tie forceps but
they allow you to grasp my procedure for
example 10 11 or 12 odd but they're more
delicate and then your needle holders
and again they do not damage the suture
material so here are some of the
resources and this PowerPoint
presentation will be available to you
afterwards so you have a copy of these
but one of the resources is dr. Hoyt and
who does microsurgical workshops at a
loss for quite a bit now he does a basic
and advanced I workshop and you can
learn quite a bit there and he goes over
a lot of these items in quite detail and
there are some other resources that are
listed here which i would suggest
catching up on because one of the
challenges there for laboratory animal
science especially for rodent surgery
there are not a lot of resources and
also there are other resources are
available we would love to hear from you
if you could let us know so we also need
to consider instrument size and length
so inappropriate size of the instrument
is going to lead to poor surgical
technique so for example if your needle
holders are too large they're going to
hinder grasping of the microsurgical
needle I'm and if they're too big for a
little manipulating that needle within
the abdomen of the mouse will be
challenging if the needle holders are
too large they can also change the shape
of the needle which will increase the
tissue drag as you
pulling the needle through the tissues
which is going to cause tissue trauma
which can or it does increase the risk
of infection it also decreases surgical
precision and you can exaggerate the
motions with larger instruments versus
having appropriate size needle holders
instruments with rings and there are two
large can't slip and also those that are
too small can or will restrict blood
flow and that's going to read to finger
fatigue and if you're doing something
for you know two three four minutes
might not be a big deal but if you're
doing it over a long period of time you
could have a huge impact one of the
things that you can just imagine if you
put a band around your finger and keep
it on it for a long time that's really
tight your finger is going to turn red
and it's going to lead it's going to be
quite painful and difficult to be
precise with it so same thing when you
instruments with rings are too small one
of the other aspects that's really
important also matching the surgeon's
hand size to the instrument so for
example some of the bigger hands is not
going to utilize the same
instrumentation that someone who is very
small and again that's one of the
challenges with the rodent kids that are
available out there then with this 56
instruments really they're not
applicable for every size of hand and
again like mention the type of surgeons
or people who are performing rodent
surgeries this very the background is
very diverse it instrument really needs
to be long enough so that they're not
operating ends rest on the webbing so
here if I can just demonstrate only in
the camera you can see that if I'm
holding this instrument its resting in a
webbing between my thumb and my pointing
finger so that's how the instrument
should rest and if the instrument is too
short for that that's going to decrease
the ability of you to control that
instrument also an appropriate
instruments are going to fatigue and
increase trembling and so you want to
really minimize that when you have the
appropriate instruments which again it's
going to provide you with optimal
control of the instrument and it's going
to allow you to perform your technique
correctly and precisely so thinking
about instruments shape is also
important so especially talk about micro
surgical instrumentation so you have two
options you have flat instruments so for
example if i can just Rodia so this is a
flat instrument or you can have half
round instruments as you can see this
one it's flat on this end but then on
here is round so when you hold this
instrument now again when they need to
move the tip of it I can just barely
rotate my fingers and it moves the
instrument if I have the flat instrument
I'm going to need to do home motion with
my wrist or hand to do that and again we
want to minimize the amount of motion
you're performing because you're working
with very very small structures and also
with that quite a few of you at the
beginning and the chance suggest that
the repetition can lead to fatigue so
same here if you're moving instead of
just making moving your finger your
finger tips or Sweeney to hold wrist
again with the whole risk that you can
imagine you're going to if it's being
repetitively perform it's going to lead
to more fatigue of your of your hand and
put the achievement injury so weight of
the instruments is also something to
consider and this can be a little bit of
a challenge and there's also a certainly
surgeons preference but we have titanium
instruments which are lighter than
stainless steel instruments and there
actually are extremely light and they
decrease the chance of
fatigue because obviously you don't have
to hold them as much because there are
lighter but initially if you are a
novice or beginner you would recommend
using stainless steel instruments
because the titanium instruments within
she can be too light for for you and
that's not going to allow you to control
him well but again as you become more of
an expert then it's going to be searches
preference or what to utilize for me for
example for some procedures i prefer
titanium instruments if I'm working with
for example vessels or nerves and in us
the most things those structures versus
it for example i'm doing a wall and
abdominal wall plug sure so again if
you're beginning to notice stainless
steel are good and started to start off
with and then you can as you progress
with the experience you can decide if
you would like to move to titanium
instruments so glare of instrument is
also important and especially when
you're working under a microscope and an
issue you might not recognize their pay
attention to it but over time it's going
to decrease your visual acuity you have
also I strain as a result of death glare
so there's a few solutions to that one
you can have sent blasted made finish
which are also known as brushed metal
instruments or you can have blue another
ization of titanium instruments which
eliminate or decrease that glamour but
also these days a lot of refusing a
microscope there is also different
functions that you can utilize their to
decrease declare as well different
filters but again it's this is
definitely one of those things that most
people don't pay attention to but if you
do start and i hope you will start
paying attention to that you can
definitely see the difference and and in
how your eyes are more restful after
those procedures so finding
is cost and prefer to see it as an
investment in equality of instruments so
there's really a balance there but you
need to think long term are you going to
utilize those instruments for multiple
procedures it's going to help you with
better outcomes and lead you to better
data so you should utilize or think
about all those different things when
you think about purchasing instruments
and very often I know you know
purchasing a microsurgical pack that's a
probe it can be even scary to look at
the price tag but again if you will
consider the whole project and what
percentage of the project the pricing is
I think that having that balance of
having to write appropriate surgical
simulation the investment is really
worth it so we have a question here so
do you have any thoughts about the
Italian stainless steel and other
materials used for surgical instruments
so once I hope I answer that question if
I did not please let me know so when you
think about identifying trustworthy
surgical suppliers it definitely can be
challenging these days because a lot of
the purchasing that we do is online we
don't go into the stores to look at the
instruments or actually see them but
really when there's a couple things that
can help you do that so manufacturers
mark should be visible on each
instrument if it's not I would really
think twice about purchasing those
instruments and manufacturers should
stand by their instruments and replace
them if they are found to be damaged but
not even damaged even if they're not
aligning correctly if they're not
cutting appropriately so all those
different things especially be spending
at twelve thirteen fourteen hundred
dollars online
Surgical Instrument you really want to
make sure that you have appropriate
instrument but also when you receive the
instruments you should really check in
right away and there's different tests
that you can do to make sure the
instruments are working correctly before
you actually utilize those and surgery
so I would never recommend by getting
receiving you pack autoclaving it and
then utilizing them in surgery
especially when you think about micro
surgical instruments but even a larger
instruments micro instruments as well
for example forceps might not align
correctly so all those things should be
assessed before you jump into doing
surgery but really if you can find the
sellers that have their manufacturers
mark on the instrument but also are
willing to stand by their instrument I
the most cases you will be in good hands
so also considering using the
instruments or how you're going to use
it the frequency of utilization and this
is where really comes in having spending
a little bit more of those instruments
and makes a huge huge difference because
fully designed for the manufacture
instruments like scissors for example
are going to become dull very very very
quickly and again this is where testing
your instruments on the quality
assurance of instruments is very
important because if you don't test them
and if you keep end up utilizing you
might not see how dull for example the
scissors are if utilize them a daily
basis so you should have a quality
insurance plan in place to do that
especially if your instruments are used
very very very commonly on like daily
basis or weekly basis considering
sterilization processes so in rodent
surgery and a lot of us utilize beat
sterilizers and it's it's one of those
techniques that it's going to make your
instruments brittle and tall so if you
utilize microsurgical instruments and i
would recommend strongly recommend not
to you'd use bead sterilizers because
again those instruments are I'm going to
dull and become brittle very very
rapidly autoclaving instruments is
really ideal but even before autoclaving
the instruments you want to make sure
you have the appropriate cleaning
detergents to utilize to clean the
instruments ultrasonic cleaners are
really good to get rid of all of the
debris they can't reach with the brush
for example but also if you're using
ultrasonic cleaners you want to make
sure that you don't show you know 20 30
inch I mean it's going to put on the
size but what are the tabletops very
often I see where folks put you know 10
20 instruments into one cycle and as
that ultrasonic cleaner works the
instruments when they touch each other
they can also become dull and brittle as
well so we recommend using ultrasonic
cleaners but also use it appropriately
consistent lubrication is extremely
important so you know using one of the
passages like a surgical milk and after
you sir instruments are cleaned and you
can do that before the instruments are
being autoplay so again it's sterile but
that's going to really prolong that
amount of time do you can use your
instruments so just as an example and
the kid that now it's a little bit over
probably 12 years or so and I still
still works quite well the microsurgical
kid is about 10 or 12 10 11 instruments
but again I've been taking care of it
quite well and also not sharing the
instruments and I know that can be also
very challenging in a group we are
multiple people to utilize surgical
instrumentation but they can be subject
to consider as well again long term and
if you are sharing instruments you're
definitely going to replace them more
often or should replace a hormone so
when you think about a broken
instruments again there are a lot of
standard kits available out there for
rodent for mice and rats performing
surgeries but again you know having four
or five six instruments for all of the
different procedures together utilize
and is really not appropriate so you
have to consider when you buy and
prepackaged surgical kids from my cell
and rents are they really appropriate
for you there are a couple companies
that are now starting to package them
for specific procedures so for example
doing catheterization procedures or
gastrointestinal procedures also
indiscriminate use of instruments so
what we talked about you don't want to
use your needle holders and for anything
else but holding needles and appropriate
sized needles and also it's really cool
to remember that mice and rats do not
equal larger species so instruments will
be different and that's the micro
estimate as well as the micro
instruments but a 4G there's lack of
references that are out again going to
some of the workshops and that I
mentioned at a loss with dr. Hoyt he
also has written a few publications on
that as well describing instruments
which I reference and a slide a few
slides before this one but overall
there's really lack of reference so
ideally before you spend you know hours
and potentially even days trying to
identify what we need reaching out to
someone that has the expertise and those
procedures can be very useful and save
you a lot of frustration not just during
the selection process of procuring this
instruments but also during the actual
surgical procedures so in summary it's
really important to address the
ergonomics and the difference of
categories that we discuss today and
addressing a selection of procurement of
surgical instrumentation again spend
money upfront or mesh is investing money
up front is really worthwhile long-term
and again there's quite a few topics we
do not dress today like the
magnification elimination and supporting
equipment how to procure that as well
but again it's something that if you are
thinking about procuring is talking to
someone who has the expertise and
chatting with them so you don't
necessarily purchase wrong equipment and
it's then just going to sit there and
gonna pretty much waste your money on it
so with that set I'm going to take
questions if there are any and so let me
pass on this to Marcel since here is our
moderator fortunate and so much I fall
ownership on thank you very much for the
informative presentation as always
you're in the cutting edge of training
and surgery in a lab animal program and
I've always drawn a lot from your
presentations and and but before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A box or button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can on our first question is is could
you comment on the appropriate cleaning
of surgical instrument to stretch their
life I think you sort of mentioned that
a little bit a couple slides ago but you
care to elaborate or have you feel this
has been answered
excuse me I'm trying to pass it on back
to you so fun so thank you so much
myself for that for that question so as
we go to cleaning the instruments so one
you should right after surgery you
should clean them immediately and not
let them sit there if you can't get them
right away place them in an saline for
example as your I'm sorry not silly but
distilled water and make sure that they
stay moist today blood or any other
constancy of one or don't dry out also
utilizing appropriate brush and so very
often I would especially with the micro
surgical instruments and I see folks
utilizing metal brush for all of the
types of macro and micro instrumentation
and you need to be careful that because
you can damage as micro surgical
instrumentation so for example using
some of the rougher toothbrushes and
something that i use and doesn't seem to
be working quite well again then
stepping into the next step lubricating
your instruments after autoclaving but
really one of the big steps is really
eliminating using a beat sterilizers but
and also utilizing what i mentioned in
the presentation using that for the bold
surgical milk will extend the lifetime
significantly but really what's
important is to utilize or clean your
instruments immediately after you end up
using them and also dry them out quickly
don't let them just them air dry they're
ideally so what I do is actually I will
clean instruments but they're also dry
them off manually I'm until I don't sit
there just for some of the areas that I
can't and get to dry out that I moved to
the
backstep the next question comes from
Michelle Courtney Courtney the scripps
research institute how hard should be to
close up Harold thumb forceps I found
there is a huge difference between them
and sometimes forceps that are hard to
press to press down to repress clothes
cost me hand fatigue and sore fingers is
there a rule to use to determine what is
unacceptable pressure so that's a that's
a great question and so and I hope they
can answer that for you but a lot of it
is going to be experience and expertise
or experience with them but one you want
to make sure that they're aligned
correctly but this should press this
should close very easily if you need to
put a lot of pressure on them most
likely they're not appropriate and this
is where if you have a good surgical
manufacturer you can go back to them and
mention that and I see that very often
with micro surgical forceps for example
where it requires quite a bit of
strength to actually even close those
and again it's a relative term strength
here when we're talking about that but
this should easily close for you and
then also even when you haven't closed
it should not require a lot of strength
to close if you're getting fatigued by
just keeping your forceps closed my
recommendation would be to to change it
because you should not if you're
repeating a procedure you know
throughout the whole day you're
certainly going to be slightly fatigued
at the end but not to the extent that I
believe you're describing in this
question
the next question is also from Michelle
if you do not recommend using how these
sterilizers how do you manage your
instruments between multiple surgeries
so again and certainly not answer that
Michelle or I think most of you guys
want to hear but we're very fortunate
for us we actually have enough kids to
do that but the other part also for
example feeding multiple procedures now
you can also autoclaves they're very
short cycles I believe they're about 20
minutes or so so you get good table top
10 plays so and if let's say you have
even three sets you can autoclave the
other instruments are you prefer z
performing those procedures and also for
the certain procedures most likely you
won't need you know 10 12 instruments
for example your prayer vasectomy and
you need to do multiple of them within a
day so you're not going to need them any
instruments so buying maybe five or six
sets as you're moving forward to them
you can autoclave the other ones as you
performing the procedures so investing
in auto place again getting the ones
with the short cycles can be very very
very useful one of the things that some
folks also do is flashing your
instruments and what that means is that
you're putting your instruments into an
autoclave without wrapping them so you
can decrease debt cycle as well it's
something you can potentially use if if
you're going to have to decide between
doing that or beats there lies around I
commend doing that but again that's
necessarily not an ideal solution but
really just having the investment of
having a number of surgical kids and
having appropriate autoplay that would
be my recommendation
I could probably add to that too Japan
is that Michelle that you know it's what
you're willing to sacrifice you know if
you need to know where you're
sacrificing you're sacrificing quality
of instrumentation and and then maybe
you need to purchase them more often so
it's just if you're going to be using
the hubby sterilizer okay so the next
question comes from Russell hit be from
Santa Fe mr. banks design corporation
thank you very much sir pond and this
was a great presentation about often
these topics these are key points that
need to be addressed more frequently
best to you so that was more for coming
Thank You Russell so it's nice to get
good compliments like that thinks about
is in the cutting edge of these things
the next question comes from Valerie's
Schrader Schroeder from University of
Notre Dame is there a way to quantify
fatigue insurgents so that is a as an
excellent but also challenging question
and I don't really have a good tool to
do that and it's something that is
really being looked at and the medical
centers there were to perform human
surgeries and even there it's really
challenging so one of the things that
they talked about his residence you know
pulling you know two three days with one
or two hours of sleep and what kind of
impact that has on surgeries and there's
a lot of publication addressing that
there's also publication or repetition
so for example doing what about surgical
procedures within you know within the
same day you know doing 20 30 40
catheterization procedures over secta
means but unfortunately I do not have a
great tool we're working on developing
that assessment tool for fatigue
so currently what I would recommend is
really doing that it was like doing an
interview there are specific questions
that you could ask and I can share them
with you I believe you have my contact
information you can reach out to buy a
conference live and that they'll provide
you with my Catholic information several
questions you can ask at the end of the
day or even at the end of the week with
the folks there are performing surgery
and you can assess that way again it's
not a truly objective tool but again
it's a fantastic question and not just
myself but a lot of other folks and the
human surgical field are working on that
so I'm sorry I don't have a great answer
for you there for this one the next
question is from alejandro flores
gonzalez universidad autónoma de nuevo
leon hello Alejandra thank you for the
question and the question is do you
think that human instruments for
surgeries that are performed to the
mouth I think the tide about oral human
oral surgical instruments are optimal
for surgeries in rats so I i love that
question because with the last few
months and we actually have looked at
dental equant equipment by varying from
surgical instrumentation as well as to
even surgical microscopes and especially
lamps surgical lamps for that so we're
actually going to be obtaining one here
at a couple I've said Novartis but so
some of them can be but again you really
need to think about the length steer the
items that I mentioned so some of those
instruments are definitely can be
appropriate and I utilize some of them
but again it's really going to depend on
a procedure that you do it so I wouldn't
want to make a general statement that
all of those instruments are useful but
it's certainly one area where you can
get and be kind of limits for you in a
way from all of the other items are out
from all the other areas but again if
you're going to be doing for example in
a nerve anastomosis or you know heart
transplant those instruments will not be
appropriate in it really need to look at
my human microsurgical instrumentation
so again it's a good idea to look at and
there's certainly some great instruments
there that we can utilize but again you
really need to look at the specific
procedures and different items that that
I mentioned a presentation so I I hope
that answers your question the last
question is not really a question but
it's more of a comment from Kim taught
from research animal unity University of
Cape Town great Wow so her comment is
Kim stock in stock comment is that steam
sterilization also can also make fine
instruments blunt and blunt them so do
you would you like to comment on that
set one now sir so thank you for the
sense thank you so much for that comment
and this really does I mean any type of
cleaning that we're going to perform
it's going to blunt your instruments and
so it's really important to how you
place your instruments so you use
appropriate packaging for especially for
microsurgical stimulation they're not
touching each other here that they're
open but it is pretty much any technique
that we utilize but if you have to
compare autoclaving versus using a beat
sterilizer 23 no comparison there the
beats their lies is going to damage the
sistrum ins a lot faster than
autoclaving so at this point I'm not
really familiar with any procedure they
would not dull your instruments and over
time when you do that
well it doesn't look like we have any
any more questions and so I want to
thank the audience for their interesting
questions and participation in today's
event and today's what webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 2015 you will receive an email
from black roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so we'll see you next
time goodbye